WHD CLARISSAPO, LEARNINGT
M RUSSIA AND BARWILL CONTINUE T
EXSENE D ID
ABOU INVAS I. TELLS UTH PLAYBOO.
SECURITYIL LAST WEEK ABOUT
RUSSIA TRYING TO CA SERIESROVOCA
JUSTIFICATIOORRERAFORWARD.
WE'VE SEEN THAT OVER THE LAST
FE
NOW THEY'RJUSTIFYING THEON OF E
THAT THEY SAID WOULD ENDOWE CONE
SITUATION
EASTERN UKRAINE, A
MEWHTING THE FORCES THEY HAV
SOLL ALONG WITE  BORDERS OVETHE0
FALSE FLAGWE'VE SEENTHOK WE LAII
U MENTIONED THE FALSE
FLAG OPERATION.HAVE TYOU ALAVARA
TALKED ABOUTA KINDRTENIT
BY A SVE A AC
UKAS
ALY IN
>> AS WE DESCR
EVERYTHING LEADI TU BE
SE PROVOCATIONS TO
OTHER NIGHT.VE PRENTIN HASMADEF
DIPLOMACY CASTDISSUA
PRESFROM CARRY
PARED TO GA PUTINANY Y AT IF TH
MEANTIME. IN TOV, TO URGE THAT N
KRAINIAN PRESIDENT ZELENSKY LL S
HE DID THA MUNICYESTERDAY.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LISTEN.lat
BOMBARDMENT WILL
R Y WILL BE FIREAFTER WE W
BE OCCUPIED.D WEEEE NCTIONEN? OE
LE MAKE  OSP
SAR RESPONSE?
>> WE'N IN VERY E
CONTACENTIRE
SIDENT IN MUNICH MET
TH.
THEY HAD VERY GOODNGN ICREIT SUV
S INCLUDING LAST YEA
E SUPPORT FO
PMONE YEAR THAN
IN ANY PVIS YEAR.I ANNOUNCEA
GUARA ORAE OF AAR
WE RALLIED OTHTOO THE SAME
TO SANCTIO HAVELT
S
PACKAGE OF SANCTIONS.
SANCTIONS IS SSIAEITERATED THER
R RUSH Y FROM
G . SOON AS YOU TRIGG THEM,
THATETGONE.
L S LONG
EFG O DO
NG TO  GENERALLY HAS P
BU LAY OUT THE
NCBEAT
PLAN AGAINSTHE TO TR
HRY CLEARLY, ANE G7LE
E PACKAGE ILL APIDLYUN
THE UNITED STATES AND EUROPETRI
THGHE'
ETING NOTIONS.
- PRESIDENT BIDEN ID
RUECO
E, YOUE SAYINGT OS
SOCH IS IT?T.
ALT OU HAV
LEADERH REF
TROOP RDER BEING T TIN- SSG TO
INVADE AT ANAV
ORDO HAVETHATTO
WITH YPLEASE IMPOSE
NO THENOT YET?IRST, WE'VE ALRED
SA
TION IRKING FOR E SANCTION
RUSSIAN SETYS TRYING TO DESTIZE
FROM, BUT E
ASRE WHILE NT HAS
DYE IS
CASTL UAY AND UNE TANKS AROVINGE
ACTUALLY DROPP
DIPLOMACY AN
PU DECISION WE
BELIHES  VER
E RISKIN
WO LY THIS WEEK E WE
7.SE EVERYL WE
COURSEOF
IF THAT DOESN'EEF
COWNDSIA THEN THEOR
VERY, AR
S ?ANT
EN, EVERY MOVE TT
THATLL PLA
FRONT OF THE SECURITCOUNL,HE AL
CHANCE, EVERNG SEEIN
SERI ON
VERYTHING  TO Y TO PREVENT IT BI
HAIF HESW
THROUGH, TO IMASSIVE
PROVIDE FOR E'S ON
DEFENSE AND TO NAT
RES
ABOUT TH I
WI
ER TCAUSE ALL OFS
REINFOEDSOLIDARITY, S
REINFORCED NATO ON ITS E
I ICH WITH T LEARS OUR PARTNERS
Y NEVER SEEN A MEHED URER
FOLLOWWITH THEAT IF PUTI
REY ALSO UKRAIETEDAD OUNCIL ON
FOIGHARD AT THE
LS
STANDOFF TTCNTHS PERHAPS W UKRA.
EQ FIRST, THAT'S A
IT'S EXACTLY WANNOUNCED IOARANT
JUST
THAT'S ON TOP OF PREVIOUARANTEE
UKRAINE TA4
BIION TO SHORE UP ITS
ATAME TIMEHE
ARE G , BO
ON A DIRECT COUNTR C
S  EUREA
N MAKIUKRAIN
WE'RALPING UKRAINE WORK  IMF ITS
MAKE SURE ITS FEET ->>OULD PUTIS
T HE
HE JUSCHOKES THE
>>ARITH AL
H ALLIES ANDS ON
THAT IT TAKES, TE HE ACTIONS
ACTIONS THAT WOULD
E GOING YOU DIAC
MEETING WITHHE
MINISTERSE
THAT'S GOI TO PPS  W
SIS T PUD TOTIE
GOTO
D F
SUGGESTED WE MEET  WEEK.
OKAY, THE MEETIN
PR RUSSIINVADEUKRAINE IN THE INE
THERE.PE HE'LL BE THE,YT TO
SEE IF WE CAN ADVANCE UTS  CREA
CA
RENGTHEN SECURITY
A THE USTATES, FOR EUROPE, IF W
TH